just hours ago Senator Chuck Grassley
sent the White House comms team into
scramble mode he dropped what is known
as an fd-1023 form and it details how
the bidens allegedly coerced the barisma
CEO to pay them millions to get rid of
the Ukrainian prosecutor who is
investigating the company back in 2016.
now the FBI interview detailed inside
was of a highly credible Source Who said
that barisma hired Hunter Biden to
protect you the U.S through his dad from
all kind of problems now I'll let Joe
Biden explain what happened next I said
I'm telling you you're not getting a
billion dollars I said you're not
getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money oh son of a
got fired
looks like someone got money joining me
now Jonathan Turley professor of law at
GW and Fox News contributor Professor
after receiving information from the
fraud Christopher Steele the FBI filed
for surveillance warrants but after the
allegations from this source
no such moves
essentially just dropped it
very interesting right
it is interesting thank you Laura the uh
fascinating thing about this story is it
just it gets worse by the day you know
one of the more interesting things that
we saw in recent weeks was Bill Barr
being interviewed and Barr said that he
never shut down this investigation but
he also added that he sent it to a U.S
attorney's office that he said found
facts that the FBI overlooked now that
alone was sort of chilling you know the
FBI has a source saying that Biden is
accepting millions of dollars and that
we now know that this Source reportedly
said that this was money to be paid to
Hunter for the protection from his dad I
mean you you can't get more serious in
that and yet when Barr sent it to the
U.S attorney's office which is not there
to investigate crimes he said they found
additional material that the FBI
overlooked it was then sent to Delaware
and there it appeared years to have died
and so there are so many questions that
we need to have answered of why this
took such a circuitous route why the FBI
didn't fully investigate what did the
U.S attorney's Office find in addition
but most importantly what happened why
did it go to Delaware and it was never
seen again
well the whistleblowers yesterday uh
Jonathan were asked about this
particular form watch this the team that
was in charge of investigating the Biden
family for tax crimes
never received the FBI document that
alleged Joe Biden was involved in a
bribery scheme for the IRS investigators
on the case the answer is no there is
things that are contained on that
document that could further corroborate
other information
and now we we find in the document that
apparently the source described as
highly credible said that the prosecutor
has many text messages and recordings to
show that he was coerced by the bidens
to make these payments to try to hold
that prosecutor off against the company
barisma in Ukraine text messages and
documents that's
that's right Lauren the other thing
about this uh this document is that it
dovetails perfectly with what Comer and
other chairman have found uh also
including the recent disclosures from
Ways and Means about how money went to
the Biden family the document refers to
how they were not supposed to send money
to the quote big guy a term we've seen
in other files is referencing President
Biden but it said that the bidens prefer
to use a Labyrinth of different accounts
different corporations to hide the money
well these committees have put together
a detailed account of just layers upon
layers of Corporations and accounts used
and it doesn't seem like there's any
purpose to this complexity except to
hide these these these transfers of
money and so it's the the most
disturbing thing about the document is
that it mirrors what was recently
released by these committees looking at
the actual transactions from these Banks
well at this point given everything we
have should the Attorney General appoint
some type of special counsel independent
Council to get to the bottom of this
Jonathan I mean I'm not a big fan of
independent councils personally but what
about that
well not only has there been an
unassailable case for a special counsel
for two years Garland has proved the
need for a special counsel every
decision he has made uh has been against
giving transparency and and affording
action to these allegations I mean the
record of the FBI shows precisely why we
need an independent special counsel the
reluctance of Garland to make that
appointment is baffling at best I mean
the the president is all over these
files there's references to his
receiving a potential cut a percentage
of some of these deals the President
also stands contradicted you know
yesterday representative Goldman tripped
the wire in the middle of the hearing
and actually got a witness to say yeah
Hunter spoke to the president about his
business dealings that's saying that the
president's been lying for two years
well Trump's impeached for a phone call
and you get all these transactions and
all these documentary evidence and it's
like no we're not doing anything
Professor great to see you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else